c'est dans la résidence universitaire
jussieu à villeurbanne qu'un jeune homme
a sauté d'une fenêtre du cinquième étage
ce vendredi soir actuellement
hospitalisé avec un pronostic vital
engagé
personne n'a pu anticiper l'acte de
détresse de cet étudiant en première
année de master de droit à l'université
lyon iii c'est la faculté avait été
ouverte
si il allait voir ses camarades
peut-être qu'un d'entre eux auraient pu
se dire mais tu vas pas bien aujourd'hui
tu as l'air patrac tu veux en parler
viens on va on va en parler ensemble on
va on aurait sans doute pu le détecter
ou même ses professeurs
les raisons de ce geste ne sont donc pas
déterminé pour le moment mais nombre
d'élèves et de professeurs ont ce même
sentiment
romain narbonne et lui a été l'un des
premiers à trouver son camarade sur le
sol sous le choc
il a posté sur facebook un cri de
détresse face à l' isolement des jeunes
d'autant plus palpable
en cette période de crise sanitaire
résultat en l'espace de quelques heures
des centaines de commentaires
d'étudiants dont certains qui pensent
qu'à passer à l'acte d'après ce jeune
homme de 19 ans le co vite 19 juillet
pour quelque chose
le quoran un virus est temps est un
facteur très aggravant il met des
multiplications sur les faiblesses des
étudiants nous n'avons plus nos petits
boulots nos jeunes et nos jobs étudiants
n'existe quasiment plus pour ma part moi
qui étais serveurs j'ai subi un
licenciement économique
ensuite nous sommes tous isolés
c'est quelque chose qui quitte tout
nouveau qu'il vient d'arriver
mais c'est quelque chose qui devient
terrible eric carpano le président de
l'université lyon iii a indiqué qu'une
cellule d'écouté psychologique avait été
mise en place ce lundi
ainsi qu'un numéro vert pour accompagner
les étudiants et tous ceux qui en
auraient besoin